GOOD AFTERNOON.
WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED.
HE WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED WITH OUR MEETING
HERE TODAY -- TODAY THIS IS THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
OF SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE WE
BEGIN WE ARE WILL BEGINNING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE -- AS WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM WHEN WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM WILL TAKE ROLE AND WE'LL
WE'LL GO FROM THERE.
COMMITTEE OF FIFTEEN THERE'S
THREE OF US SO WE HAVE A WAYS TO
GO -- SO WE WILL HEAR TWO
WITNESSES PER SIDE WITH THE TIME
LIMIT OF THREE MINUTES EACH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
ASKED TO STATE ONLY YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION FOR THE
RECORD AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
MEASURE.
THERE ARE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT TODAY --
ANY MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
REMOVE A BILL FROM CONSENT OF
THE ITEMS ARE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
ONE FIFTY FOUR BY DR PAN.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH IS A HEALTH COMMITTEE
BILL.
SO WITH THAT -- THE FIRST AND WE
WE TAKE THIS AND FILE ORDER SO
THE FIRST -- ITEM BEFORE US IS A
SENATE BILL TWENTY FOURS -- BY --
SENATOR LABOR PLEASE COME ON UP
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MY ON THE VIDEO.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF -- FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND THAT
YOU KNOW THAT I WILL BE HAPPILY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT SUGGESTED ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THIS
US SUPREME COURT RULED THAT THE
DUE PROCESS CLAUSE OF THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT. TO THE
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
THAT PROTECTS A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE AN
ABORTION.
AS WE ALL KNOW THIS LANDMARK
CASE WAS ROE VERSUS WADE.
NOW ALMOST A HALF A CENTURY
LATER PEOPLE GROUPS AND
INSTITUTIONS HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING THEY CAN THINK OF TO
RESTRICT ACCESS.
AND TO SHAME ANY WOMAN WHO
CHOOSES TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
THOUGH OUR FORMER GOVERNOR MAY
HAVE BELIEVE THAT IT WAS NOT
UNREASONABLE. FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO TRAVEL OFF CAMPUS TO
ASK ACCESS MEDICATION ABORTION.
I RESPECTFULLY AND PROFOUNDLY
DISAGREE.
MEMBERS JUST THREE YEARS AGO A
GROUP OF COMMITTED UC BERKELEY
STUDENTS STARTED GRASSROOTS
EFFORT TO BRING MEDICATION
ABORTION TO THEIR ON CAMPUS
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
AFTER SPEAKING TO THEIR
ADMINISTRATION AND RAISING
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO THAT END.
THEY WERE REJECTED BY THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION AT WHICH POINT I
WAS ASKED TO LEAD THE EFFORT
HERE AT THE CAPITOL.
SB TWENTY FOUR IS A CONTINUATION
OF THAT EFFORT.
THE COLLEGE STUDENT RIGHT TO ACT
ACCESS ACT WOULD REQUIRE ALL ON
CAMPUS STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS AT
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION FOR EARLY PREGNANCY
TERMINATION. FOR THEIR STUDENTS
BY JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE RESEARCH FROM UC SAN
FRANCISCO ESTIMATES THAT EVERY
MONTH FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
STUDENTS AT THE THIRTY FOUR UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES.
SICK MEDICATION ABORTIONS ON OUT
OF SIGHT HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
IF WE TRULY VALUE ACCESS TO
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORT OF
SUPPORTING STUDENT SUCCESS THEN
IT'S CRITICAL THAT THESE
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS EVERY MONTH.
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS AS THESE
SERVICES ON CAMPUS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A TWO
STEP PROCESS WHERE A PATIENT
TAKES TWO SETS OF PILLS OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO DAYS DURING THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
ACCORDING TO A UC SAN FRANCISCO
STUDY MEDICATION ABORTION IS
VERY SAFE WITH MAJOR
COMPLICATIONS OCCURRING IN ONLY
ZERO POINT 3% OF CASES.
MAKING IT SAFER THAN TYLENOL OR
****.
THOUGH MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
SUCH AS PREGNANCY OPTIONS
COUNSELING AND CONTRACEPTIVES
NONE CURRENTLY OFFER ACCESS TO
MEDICATION ABORTION ON CAMPUS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS
CLINICALLY SIMPLER THAN MUCH OF
THE CARE ALREADY OFFERED AT
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS SUCH AS
DIABETES MANAGEMENT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE.
AND DIAGNOSIS OR TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
ACCESS IS SEVERELY LIMITED FOR
STUDENTS SINCE ONLY 15%.
OF THE CLOSEST OFF CAMPUS
ABORTION PROVIDERS ARE OPEN ON
WEEKENDS.
MEETING THAT STUDENTS MAY HAVE
TO MISS CLASS EXAMS AND WORK TO
ACCESS ABORTION.
WHICH IS SUPREME COURT
DETERMINED ALMOST HALF A CENTURY
AGO IS A PROTECTED
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS MEDICATION
ABORTION ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
CRITICAL SINCE WOMEN MUST
RECEIVE THIS CARE WITHIN THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
AND MOST WOMEN DON'T EVEN KNOW
THEY'RE PREGNANT UNTIL THEY'RE
FIVE OR SIX WEEKS ALONG.
MEMBERS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
ISN'T JUST A SLOGAN BUT RATHER
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING TRUE
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR STATE
INCLUDED COLLEGE STUDENTS.
ARE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES HERE
WITH ME TODAY IS DOCTOR DANIEL
CRESSMAN A PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
SCIENCES.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO AND DIRECTOR OF
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH RESEARCH
PROGRAM AND GRACE PAYING A
STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY [inaudible]
DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE -- AS
SENATOR AND MENTION I'M A
PHYSICIAN AND PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS
GYNECOLOGY AT UCSF -- IN OUR
RESEARCH PROGRAM HAS PUBLISHED
TWO STUDIES IN PEER REVIEW
JOURNALS.
RELATED TO THE COLLEGE STUDENT
RIGHT TO ACCESS ACT.
THE FIRST LOOKED AT HOW OFTEN
STUDENTS SEEK ABORTION CARE AND
WHETHER THEY FACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES OBTAIN APPROXIMATELY
THOUSAND WORSENS EACH MONTH.
AND WE ESTIMATE THAT AS MANY AS
FIVE HUNDRED MEDICATION
ABORTIONS WOULD BE PROVIDED
MONTHLY ON CAMPUS IS STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS OFFER THAT
SERVICE.
ACROSS ALL PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES CONSIDERING THAT THIS
SERVICE REQUIRES TWO VISITS.
THE MEDIAN TIME BY PUBLIC PUBLIC
TRANSPORT -- TO THE CLOSEST
PROVIDER IS TWO HOURS ROUND TRIP
FOR MEDICATION ABORTION AND IT'S
UP TO FOUR HOURS FOR SOME
CAMPUSES.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA CODE
OF REGULATIONS TRAVELING MORE
THAN THIRTY MINUTES FOR HEALTH
CARE RENTERS THAT CARE
INACCESSIBLE. FOR THE SECOND
STUDY WE LOOK AT THE CAPACITY OF
THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS TO
PROVIDE MEDICATION ABORTION ON
CAMPUS AND WHAT THEY WOULD NEED.
ALL THE UC AND CSU STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS ALREADY PROVIDE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES --
THE EMPLOYEE OR CONTRACT WITH AT
LEAST ONE POSITION -- WORDED
VANCE PRACTICE CLINICIAN -- AND
THEY HAVE THE NEEDED PHYSICAL
SPACE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION THEY WOULD
ALL NEED TRAINING -- THEY WITH
THE ULTRASOUND IF THAT'S NEEDED --
AND TWENTY FOUR HOUR TELEPHONE
SUPPORT TO TRIAGE PATIENTS IF
THEY DON'T ALREADY HAVE THAT SET
UP.
GIVEN THESE FINDINGS I BELIEVE
THAT ABORTION COMPETE CARE ON
CAMPUS IS NECESSARY TO IMPROVE
ACCESS IN DECREASE BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS.
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WITH THE
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN COMMITTED IT
WOULD BE VERY FEASIBLE TO OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION AT THE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
THERE'S NO REASON TO EXCLUDE
MEDICATION ABORTION FROM THE
CARE THAT IS ALREADY PROVIDED --
AT STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS.
SENATOR LEVIN NOTED MEDICATION
PORTION IS SAFE AND SIMPLE TO
PROVIDE OVER THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION WOMEN IN THE UNITED
STATES OF HAD A MEDICATION
ABORTION.
AND SERIOUS COMPLICATIONS ARE
VERY RARE IN FACT THE HEALTH
RISKS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
FOR WOMEN WHO CHOOSE TO CONTINUE
A PREGNANCY TO TERM.
THAN THEY ARE FOR WOMEN WHO
CHOOSE MEDICATION ABORTION.
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO.
THE FDA APPROVED A NEW GENERIC
FORM OF MIFEPRISTONE WHICH IS
THE MAIN DRUG USED MEDICATION
ABORTION FURTHER CONFIRMING THE
AGENCY'S VIEW THAT THIS IS A
VERY SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT.
THOUSANDS OF UC AND CSU STUDENTS
GET PREGNANT EACH YEAR WHILE
ATTENDING SCHOOL AND WITH THE
TRAINING -- THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL MAKE POSSIBLE I
BELIEVE THAT NOT ONLY WILL
ABORTION ACCESS BE EXPANDED FOR
STUDENTS BUT THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS WILL IMPROVE THEIR
OVERALL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES.
INCLUDING MISCARRIAGE MANAGEMENT
TIMELY REFERRALS -- FOR
PREGNANCY RELATED COMPLICATIONS.
AS WELL AS PROVISION OF A WIDER
RANGE OF CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS GRACE PAYING
AND I'M A SOPHOMORE AT SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY ORIGINALLY FROM
OAKLAND.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY.
THIS YEAR I BEGAN ORGANIZING ON
MY CAMPUS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE
INCLUDING ABORTION CARE.
AS A LOW INCOME FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT OF COLOR IT IS IMPORTANT
TO ME TO FIGHT FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE TO THE OTHER
STUDENTS DOWN THE LINE DON'T
HAVE.
TO RIGHT NOW WITH OTHER STATES
PASSING LAWS THAT BAN ABORTION
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR TO
BE A LEADER IN EXPANDING ACCESS
TO CARE.
EVEN IN THE STATE WITHOUT MAJOR
ABORTION RESTRICTIONS WE KNOW AS
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY STUDENTS OF
COLOR STUDENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
PARENTS.
STUDENTS STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET AND OTHER MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES STILL FACE OBSTACLES
ACCESSING ABORTION.
MY CAMPUS HAS THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF HOMELESS STUDENTS IN THE CSU
SYSTEM.
AN UNACCEPTABLE 13% OF US HAVE
UNSTABLE HOUSING.
SLEEPING IN CARS AT FRIENDS
HOUSES AND IN THE LIBRARY. 42%
OF CSU STUDENTS DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEIR NEXT MEAL IS COMING FROM.
STUDENTS I KNOW DON'T ALL HAVE
CARS ARE ANXIOUS ABOUT GOING TO
PROVIDER THAT THEY DON'T KNOW.
THE EXTRA COSTS FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO AN OFF CAMPUS
ABORTION PROVIDER ARTS THE
STRESS THAT STUDENTS ARE ALREADY
FACING TRYING TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS.
THIS IS A STUDENT HEALTH ISSUE
AND ACADEMIC RETENTION ISSUE AND
ULTIMATELY AN EQUITY ISSUE.
I SERVE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND I'M
PROUD THAT THIS YEAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE ASSOCIATION
ENDORSED SB.
TWENTY FOUR TOGETHER WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WHICH ALSO
ENDORSED THE BILL WE REPRESENT
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT
SUPPORT ABORTION KAREN CAMPUS.
I URGE YOU TO TRUST US STUDENTS
AND VOTE YES SB TWENTY FOUR
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SO THIS IS JUST BE.
IS TO TURN MEMBERS WHEN ASKING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LATINAS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE PROUD CO
SPONSOR THE BILL HERE IN SUPPORT.
PERFECT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SANTIAGO CHOPPY
Là ALUMNI OF UC SANTA CRUZ IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI AM CARLY EVEN THERE -- UC
BERKELEY ALUMNI IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FINALLY IN DOUBLE
YOUR NUMBER USE YOUR SAID IN A
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS SANDY HERNANDEZ
I'M FROM YOU SEE OUR AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI STEPHANIE IS A WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN SUPPORT.
MY RIBS IN PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT.
IF YOU WERE TO WITH
PLANTAGINACEAE ACTION AT UC
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MELLIE OPPORTUNISM
SITTING YOU SEE OUR AND I'M
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
TO HI AM THIRTY AMALIE -- FOR ME
IS THE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HYMAN IS AN ASSEMBLY LIKE I'M A
STUDENT AT PITZER COLLEGE IN A
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS TO FEAR MANCHU
STUDENT FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GENERATION ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI AM DEANNA DURAN AS CSU
NORTHRIDGE PUBLIC HEALTH OF THE
ALUMNI AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI AMHERST MARTINEZ AN
UNDERGRADUATE FROM UC MERCED AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AWESOME CHEN WAS CSU FULLERTON A
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
KATHLEEN SAYING GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GIVE OPEN OTHER USE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE AND A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JUDITH -- HARM YOU SEE ARE
ALARMED AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ALL WE A MURPHY UCLA --
UNDERGRADUATE REPRESENT IF
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE UC
STUDENT HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN
EXECUTIVE OVERSIGHT BOARD AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
FRANKIE HERNANDEZ PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HELP AGREE STUDENT I'M THOSE
COLLEGES TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
ARIANNA YALA CAPTAIN HEALTH
COLLEGE STUDENT AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI AGES ZERO SALAS YOU SEE OUR
ALUMNI HERE TO REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL NETWORK OF ABORTION
FUNDS AND ADVOCATES FOR YOU AND
STRUGGLING.
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
I'M NICOLE MADE OF FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE PRESIDENT OF MACRO
SOCIAL WORK STUDENT WORK I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I MEAN LLENA DE NAKED CHEST
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEN'S WORK INSTEAD THAT UCLA LAW
AND UC DAVIS LOVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
COURTNEY CREWS TO NOT UC DAVIS
AND MEMBER OF THE CAMPUS CHAPTER
OF CALIFORNIA WOMAN'S LISTS AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
BREAK A STRAPPY STUDENT MYSTERON
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEY IT AGAIN STUDENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MEGHAN JONES STUDENT STRONG
LAUREN LOVE PRESIDENT OF
STUDENTS REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AT
UC DAVIS AND ALSO REPRESENTING
THE A CC THE EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
COMMISSION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GET MILLER NUMBER OF OUR STUDENT
GOVERNMENT AT CALIFORNIA LOOKING
UNIVERSITY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ALONDRA SKILLED ARE CO VICE
PRESIDENT EXTERNAL FAIRS FOR SO
SHE'D STUDENTS AT SAM CISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY AND HIGH SCHOOL
FACILITATOR FOR NIGHT NATIONAL
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
REVERE WOULD STUDENT AT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
GENERATION ACTION I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HONESTLY
SORRY I AM A SOPHOMORE AT SAN
JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AND
FOUNDER PRESIDENT OF IGNITE
NATIONALLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M KEVIN RUN WITH SHELTER
ABORTION AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DR UNTIL LET'S PRACTICING OBGYN
IN SACRAMENTO AND ABORTION
PROVIDER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CAITLYN AS FAR AS A MEDICAL
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
KEVIN MOORE DOES ABI ALUMNI OF
UC RIVERSIDE AND KERR MEDICAL
STUDENT UC DAVIS CO PRESIDENT OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS FOR CHOICE AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HOW CAN MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND
FORMER REPRODUCTIVE OPTIONS
COUNSELOR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL?
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND FACULTY
STAFF LIBRARIANS COACHES AND
COUNSELLORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DAY NOVEL WITH THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND PROUD UCLA LAW
ALUMNI.
ALICE KESSLER N BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND UC DAVIS
ALUMNI IN SUPPORT.
LIBBY BENEDICT PROUD UCLA BRUIN
FROM A YEAR I'M CAN'T EVEN SAY
OUT LOUD BUT I STRONGLY ENDORSE --
HOLE FOR YOUR AYE SUPPORT AND
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA HOLD FOR ONE SECOND WE
HAVE A QUORUM SOMEONE TO TAKE
ROLE AND THEN WE CAN WILL BE --
TAKEN ACTION ON THIS BILL ONCE
WE DO THAT SO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WAIT HERE MAYES HERE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
HELLO.
BONTA.
BURKE CARRILLO FLORA.
LIMóN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM SO PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU DEBBIE
BAMBERGER NURSE PRACTITIONER
ABORTION PROVIDER AND CURRENT
UCSF DOCTORAL STUDENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
TAYLOR WAR DO YOU SEE DAVIS
ALUMNI AND CURRENT GRADUATE
STUDENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND URBAN
PLANNING AT UCLA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NOT A SECOND HERE DO YOU
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALUMNI AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SOCIAL WORK STUDENT
AT UCLA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
JACK LYNCH A VERY YOU SEE AYE
ALUMNI AND CURRENT AND TEACH
STUDENT AT UCLA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SOFIA STROMAL STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY WITH STUDENTS UNITED
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL WALLACE PUBLIC POLICY
GRADUATE STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
EARLIER VAGUE JEWISH GRADUATE
FROM UC BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
NO WELL JONES CO SPONSOR WITH.
IN TRYING TO REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE. FOR FOUR YEARS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
WHAT KIND OF THAT SIR A JUNIOR
AT UC BERKELEY AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU?
GEN FLORI ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
SHANNON HOW THIS NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
CLOSED FUNDS ON THE BILL ON
BEHALF OF OUR TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS STATEWIDE WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL CO ALUMNI OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND UC BERKELEY CLASS OF TWENTY
TWELVE WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE CO SPONSOR STRONG
SUPPORT.
I'M ALLEN ARE MUCH WARTS
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT UC
DAVIS BOARD CERTIFIED INTERNIST
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MILEY'S AT ALL WITH AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN A PRODI SAID IT WAS LAW AND I
THINK.
RIGHT SPENCER BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS TO SHIP NINE
IN SUPPORT.
RAIN X. CITIZEN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANGELA GILLIARD WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA -- WE
ARE NOT IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THE BILL MAY WE APPROACH TO
READ A BRIEF STATEMENT.
TYPICALLY WE TAKE.
OPPOSITION OR OR SUPPORT ME JUST
VERY BRIEFLY STE STATE YOUR
POSITION R
YOUR CONCERNS BRIEFLY FROM THERE
PLEASE CALL. TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA MANDATES THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE HEALTHCARE THE
UNIVERSITY OPERATES A HEALTH
PLAN FOR STUDENTS CALLED YOU SEE
SHIP.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
CONSIDERED AN ESSENTIAL BENEFIT
FOR STUDENTS IN THE UNIVERSITY
FULLY SUPPORT.
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS FOR ITS
STUDENTS WE HAVE NOT WAVERED IN
OUR RESOLVE HOWEVER YOU SEE DOES
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON SB TWENTY
FOUR BECAUSE THERE ARE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH WITH THE
AUTHOR THE ISSUES ARE PRIMARILY
AROUND IMPLEMENTATION IN COST
WHILE MOST OF THE PUBLIC
CONVERSATION SURROUNDING THE
BILL IS CENTERED ON WOMEN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
THIS IS NEVER BEEN AN ISSUE FOR
THE UNIVERSITY WE HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR ON REPEATED OCCASIONS THAT
WE SUPPORT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE.
THE PROBLEMS WITH ACCESS TO THE
SERVICE ARE NOT PROXIMITY RATHER
THE PROBLEMS FOR THAT REFERRALS
HAVE BEEN NOT.
HAVE NOT BEEN MADE SEAMLESSLY
AND THEY SHOULD BE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE UNDERSTAND THE OFFERS
I WOULD LIKE TO SERVICE ARE TO
BE PROVIDED ON CAMPUS IS
DIRECTLY WHICH WILL HELP RESOLVE
SOME OF THE INSURANCE CONNECTION
TYPE ISSUE STUDENTS HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND WE STILL NEED TO
SOLVE A FEW PROBLEMS RISEN
RELATED TO FUNDING.
BEYOND IMPLEMENTATION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BRING THE SERVICE
ON CAMPUS WITHOUT A FUNDING
SOURCE BE ON TWENTY TWENTY THREE
COULD INCREASE COSTS TO STUDENTS
SINCE STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS.
ARE SUPPORTED BY STUDENT FEES WE
KNOW WE HAVE A CHAMPION.
AND A GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH SENATOR LABOR'S OFFICE AND
ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN RESOLVE
THESE IT A YEAR -- OUT FUNDING
ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MAGGIE WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF WE ARE IN A
PENDING POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR THE ONGOING DIALOGUE.
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS
AROUND IMPLEMENTATION ON GOING
COST LIKE FOUR TO ADDRESS IN
THIS COLLABORATIVELY BUT THE
AUTHOR STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
TO TEST THE TESTIFIED THAT WILL
WILL HAVE OTHERS AND OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION AT THAT POINT SO
TESTIMONY IN UP IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SO I WAS BEFORE THREE MINUTES
EACH.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARY LEE SHRIDER
I'M -- RIGHTS LETTER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR RIGHT TO LIFE OF KERN
COUNTY AND POLITICAL ADVOCACY
CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE
I'M HERE REALLY DID -- ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO YIELD LIFE THREE
MINUTES TO A DOCTOR BRATS
[inaudible] FOR MINUTES.
ACTUALLY WE IT'S THREE MINUTES
EACH SO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M DOCTOR STEPHEN BROUGHT.
I AM IN A BOARD CERTIFIED OB TO
WEIGH IN WITH THIRTY FIVE YEARS
OF PRACTICE EXPERIENCE.
THE FIRST CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO WAS A NAVY
DOCTOR.
STATION AT THE MARINE CORPS BASE
CAMP PENDLETON AND ALSO SERVED
MANY YEARS AT THE NAVAL MEDICAL
CENTER IN SAN DIEGO IS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE OBGYN DEPARTMENT
THERE -- MY SERVER THE MARINE
CORPS FIRST MEDICAL BATTALION IN
THE SOMALIA IN THE IRAQ WAR -- I
RETIRED FROM THE NAVY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT MOVED TO
SUSANVILLE -- WANTED TO WORK IN
AN AREA WHERE THERE WAS A LOT OF
MEDICAL NEED AND I'VE REALLY
ENJOYED PRACTICING THERE FOR THE
LAST. ELEVEN YEARS MY WIFE AND I
HAVE THREE KIDS OF ALL GRADUATED
FROM CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES.
WE SERVING ON THE BOARD OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF PRO LIFE
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS.
WITH MEDICAL ABORTION I COLLEGE
CAMPUSES WHAT WILL BE THE RISK
FOR PATIENTS WITH MEDICAL
ABORTION WE FIND THAT
COMPLICATIONS ARE NOT SO RARE.
WOMEN WHO TAKE MIFEPRISTONE FOR
ABORTION HAVE MUCH GREATER RISK
OF HEMORRHAGE IN FATAL INFECTION
THE MORE FAILURES REQUIRING
EMERGENCY SURGERY THAN WOMEN WHO
HAVE SURGICAL ABORTION.
THE COMPLICATION RATE.
INCLUDING CASES OF HEMORRHAGE
INFECTION OR SURGERY WAS
PERFORMED IS IN MOST STUDIES
326% AND I'VE FILED MY
REFERENCES WITH THE MASTER AT
ARMS THERE ON FILE.
IN ONE STUDY THE RATE OF IMAGE
WAS 15% ANOTHER 17% OF PATIENTS
REQUIRED SURGERY.
COMPLICATION RATES COULD BE EVEN
HIGHER THAN WE FIND OF THE
LITERATURE BECAUSE OF
DIFFICULTIES WITH BILLING CODES
IN LARGE NUMBERS OF PATIENTS
LOST TO FOLLOW UP IN SOME
STUDIES.
SO ROUGHLY ONE OUT OF EVERY
TWENTY WOMEN WHO HAVE MEDICAL
ABORTION WILL HAVE A
COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS BLEEDING
SOMETIMES RECORDING A BLOOD
TRANSFUSION.
AND OR NEED NEED FOR SURGERY
BECAUSE OF PREGNANCY TISSUE LEFT
INSIDE THE UTERUS.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND IN THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE
WERE FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE ADVERSE EVENTS
REPORTED TO THE FDA INCLUDING
TWENTY FOUR DEATHS NINETY SEVEN
ECTOPIC PREGNANCIES.
OVER THOUSAND HOSPITALIZATIONS
EXCLUDING DEATHS IN FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY NINE BUT TRANSFUSIONS AND
FORMER TWELVE INFECTIONS.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
THESE ADVERSE EVENT REPORTS.
I HAVE A WHOLE SIX MINUTES.
THE SEVENTY THREE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES OKAY -- SO THE THE
BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT SOME
COMPLICATIONS ARE GOING TO OCCUR.
AND THE QUESTION IS ARE WE READY
TO HANDLE THOSE COMPLICATIONS.
CONTINUITY OF CARE SOMETHING WE
STRIVE FOR AND SAFEGUARD
PATIENTS TO MAINTAIN QUALITY
WITH ESPECIALLY MEDICAL ABORTION
PATIENTS HAVING COMPLICATIONS
SOMETIMES FIND THAT THE CLINIC
IS CLOSED AND SHOW UP IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM.
IF IF THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
HOTLINE IS TELLING PATIENTS TO
GO TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM IT'S
NOT GOOD CONTINUITY OF CARE --
ULTRASOUND -- PROCEDURES NEED
SUPERVISION TRAINING DOCTORS AND
NURSES TO DO THAT WILL BE
DIFFICULT.
AND OF WE'RE REQUIRE A LARGE
VOLUME OF PATIENTS -- FOR
SUPERVISED ULTRASOUND TRAINING.
THIS BILL WANT ME TO STATE ABOVE
OBJECTIVES -- MISS FOR STONE
ABORTIONS WILL BE INCONVENIENT
FOR PATIENTS TAKING MUCH LONGER
TO COMPLETE COMPARED WITH
SURGICAL ABORTION MEDICAL
PORTION OF COURSE A VISIT TO
RECEIVE THE DRUGS HOURS OR DAYS
OF CRAMPING AND BLEEDING A
POSSIBLE YOUR VISIT.
AND THEN FOLLOW UP WITH THE
CLINIC AGAIN ACCORDING TO DATA
COMPILED BY CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE ABORTION CLINICS LOCATED AN
AVERAGE OF ONLY SIX MILES FROM
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
HI IS A PHYSICIAN OF CONCERN FOR
THE QUALITY OF CARE LACK OF CARE
PATIENTS WITH COMPLICATIONS
RECEIVE AND FOR THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS ABILITY TO MANAGE THESE
COMPLICATIONS AS A CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYER VETERAN A PRO LIFE
CALIFORNIAN.
I POSE AND ASK YOU TO DEFEAT SB
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION PLEASE SO MY NAME IS
JOSEPH DUNCAN I'M A GOD FEARING
CHRISTIAN AND BASED UPON ALL THE
GOD FEARING CHRISTIANS I'M OF
CHOOSING THIS BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHANE CALDERON A BORN
AGAIN CHRISTIAN ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE INNOCENT CHILDREN IN THE
WOMB I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IN JESUS NAME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU GO TO RIGHT TO LIFE OF
KERN COUNTY IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL -- IN HAND I USE FOR
LIFE FROM UC DAVIS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
IN A BALK AT THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL COORDINATOR
FOR STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF AMERICA
REPRESENTING NINETY STUDENT
GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND TWELVE HUNDRED STING GROUPS
NATIONALLY AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
TWENTY FOUR RYAN BRACK ME PROUD
NINETEEN EIGHTY GRADUATE A UC
SANTA BARBARA I OPPOSE.
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD FROM SAN
FRANCISCO -- NUMBER OF PRO LIFE
SEVEN CISCO AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON SB TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
MY SEVEN ON THE FLOOR IS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS LAURIE BROUGHT SOME A
REGISTERED NURSE WORKING IN
LABOR AND DELIVERY A STRONG
CLICK POSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH THOMAS I'M A
GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY HAYWARD AND A MEMBER
OF ST MARY'S CHURCH IN VACAVILLE
AND I STRONGLY.
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
WHEN AT SALES DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE AND ON
BEHALF OF INCREASING NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO RECOGNIZE THE
HUMANITY OF THE CHILD IN THE
WOMB AND THE TRAUMA ABORTION
CAUSES WOMEN?
A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
CARLY HEIL ST MARY'S RESPECT
LIFE TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MARY SERI MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER
FORMER REGISTERED NURSE IN LABOR
AND DELIVERY.
I FORMALLY REALLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
LINDA MENINA REGISTERED NURSE
GRADUATE OF UC SAN FRANCISCO ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
REVEREND OLDER HERMAN AND WITH
THE OF LIFE TEAMS INTERNATIONAL
AND THE PER COUNSEL UNITED
STATES WE STRONGLY OPPOSE OF
THIS MEASURE YOUNG PEOPLE THESE
ARE YOUR BABIES THANK YOU.
GREAT BURKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY IT COUNCIL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THINGS.
CHENEY ISSUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
WITH ANY SEC ACCOUNT POLY I'D
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
REYES JOHN SHOOT BAKERSFIELD I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M RALPH MORE LOUDLY A NINETEEN
SEVENTY GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE AND
A MEMBER OF SAINT ROSE CATHOLIC
PARISH STYLE SACRAMENTO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE IS DANGEROUS
AND UNNECESSARY BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OPEN ROMBERG UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA ALANIS REPRESENTING
PRENATAL MURDER OPPONENTS ASKING
YOU TO OPPOSE PRENATAL MURDER.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS THE STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
I'M SORRY WE WERE ON THE
IMPRESSION THAT IF I YIELDED HE
COULD HAVE ALL SIX CAN I CAN I
HAVE A MINUTE.
YOU COULD HAVE ONE MINUTE I CAN
IN ONE MINUTE VERY GOOD -- IN
COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON THE BILL
WITNESS TESTIMONY AND
LEGISLATORS INQUIRE HE'S FOCUSED
ON MEDICATION ABORTIONS
PERCEIVED IMPEDIMENTS TO
PREGNANT STUDENTS ACCESS TO SUCH
ABORTIONS AND RELATED COSTS AND
LIABILITY CONCERNS.
HOWEVER AT NO TIME HAS ANYONE
POSE THE MOST RELEVANT QUESTION
IS ABORTION MEDICATION BY
TECHNIQUES THE MOST EFFECTIVE
METHOD IN REACHING THE STATED
GOALS OF SB.
TWENTY FOUR RESEARCH BY
RECOGNIZED EXPERTS IN OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY STRONGLY
INDICATES IT IS NOT IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE OF SB THREE TWENTY
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN DISMISSED
THE BILL AS A NECESSARY.
BUT HE WAS ONLY HALF CORRECT NOT
ONLY ARE ABORTIONS MY MEDICATION
TECHNIQUES UNNECESSARY ON
COLLEGE CAMPUS THEIR COUNTRY
INDICATED.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS A PRO CHOICE
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATION WITHIN
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND MEMBERS
WOMEN WHO DESIRE QUICK ABORTION
QUICK COMPLETION OF THE ABORTION
PROCESS.
ARE NOT CONSIDERED GOOD
CANDIDATES FOR MEDICAL ABORTIONS
ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT --
ANYTHING THAT THE FACT THAT
ANYTHING SPEECH GUNS ABORTIONS
IS A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT DOES
NOT PRECLUDE CITIZENS FROM
IMPLEMENTING SOME LIMITED
RESTRICTIONS -- LAW ABIDING
PERMIT CARRYING GUN OWNERS
CANNOT CURE THEIR GUNS
EVERYWHERE THEY WISH.
INCLUDING INTO THIS CAPITOL
BUILDING AND AS A MATTER OF
CONSISTENCY.
IT IS NOT THE STATE'S ROLE TO
MAKE SURE CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT
HOLDERS HAVE ACCESS TO ALL THE
FIREARMS THEY DESIRE THEN IT IS
LIKE WHY IS NOT THE STATE'S ROLE
TO MANDATE.
THE COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE NEVER
INCONVENIENCED IN PURSUIT OF
UNLIMITED ACCESS TO ABORTIONS
NOR IS IT STATES ROLE TO MANDATE
THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES BE
OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
ABORTIONS ON THEIR PREMISES.
AND FURTHER MORE TO BE OPEN TO
USING STUDENT FEES TO DO SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WAS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
HI SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE TO BRING THIS BILL BACK
AGAIN INTO THE LEGISLATURE I'M
PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR. FOR SB TWENTY FOUR AND
HAVE SOME PREPARED REMARKS THAT
I'D LIKE TO SHARE.
IN LIGHT OF RECENT EVENTS IN
ALABAMA LOUISIANA GEORGIA IT IS
OUR DUTY AS LEGISLATORS TO
UPHOLD AND PROTECT THE
GUARANTEED RIGHTS TO ABORTION
AXIS.
THAT IS CURRENTLY UNDER ATTACK
NOT ONLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND I WOULD SAY AROUND
THE WORLD.
SB TWENTY FOUR WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THE RIGHT IT'S PROTECTED
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THAT
THE RIGHT IT'S UP HELD.
THROUGH ALL ALL PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING SEE
ISSUES AND UC'S.
BASIC HEALTH SERVICES EVEN ON
THE CSU IN THE UC CAMPUSES
INCLUDE PREGNANCY COUNSELING
CONTRACEPTIVES.
AND OTHER REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES
BUT ARBITRARILY BUT ARBITRARILY
STOP SHORT OF MEDICATION
ABORTIONS.
THIS LACK OF AXIS.
COST IS UNNECESSARY LOGISTICAL
AND FINANCIAL STRESS TO
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD THIS IS
NOT AN ISSUE THAT ONLY IMPACTS
WOMEN.
THIS IS AN AND THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT IMPACTS BOTH PARTNERS IN
THAT SITUATION BOTH MALE AND
FEMALE.
THE LACK OF AXES CLEARLY IS AN
ISSUE ALTERNATIVE MEDICAL
FACILITIES AND TREATMENTS OFF
CAN'T MISS ARE OFTEN NOT AN
OPTION GIVEN THAT 51% OF
STUDENTS AND ROLLED ACROSS THE
ISSUES IN U. S. AND UC'S.
ARE LOW INCOME AND A PORTION OF
UC STUDENTS AND SEE IF YOU
STUDENTS TO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION.
ALLOWING ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
GUARANTEES A SAFE OUTLET FOR
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
WHO DESERVE ACCESS TO THESE LIFE
ALTERING TREATMENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITIES WHERE THEY ARE SAFE?
AND IN A SOUND PLACE.
OFFERING MEDICATION ABORTION AT
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES WILL ENSURE
THE PHYSICAL MENTAL AND
FINANCIAL WELL BEING OF OUR
STUDENTS IT'S PRIORITIZE.
STUDENTS MUST HAVE THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION ACCESS AND THEY MUST BE
GIVEN THE NECESSARY SERVICES
REQUIRED TO FOCUS ON AND PURSUE.
THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS I AM
PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR FOR SB.
TWENTY FOUR AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND
THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN THE RIGHTS
TO REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
AND INCOME AND ENSURE THAT THE
YOUNG MEN WHO ARE ALSO EQUALLY
AS RESPONSIBLE -- ARE ALSO AT
THE TABLE AND ENSURE THAT THEIR
PARTNERS ARE SAFE -- AT THE
COLLEGE CAMPUSES SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR FOR HAVING THE COURAGE
TO BRING THIS UP AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
MISS WALDRON [inaudible]
SO -- I KNOW THE GOVERNOR VETOED
THE BILL BEFORE.
NO WAS BASED ON THE FACT THAT.
THERE'S SERVICES WITHIN UNDER
FIVE MILES TO SEVEN MILES OF
THIRTY THREE OR SO OF THE
CAMPUSES ALREADY -- SO SINCE
SERVICES A WIDELY AVAILABLE IN
NEARBY.
HE DEEMED THE BILL ON NECESSARY
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
WOULD BE.
NOTHING'S CHANGED IN THAT REGARD.
AS I STATED IN MY OPENING I
PROFOUNDLY DISAGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND IT'S NOT MEDICAID
ABORTION OR PORTION IN FACT IS
NOT READILY AVAILABLE -- WITHIN
ALL THIRTY FOUR CAMPUSES SO THE
GOVERNOR AND I DON'T AGREE HE
VETOED IT AND WE'RE BACK
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
I KNOW THE GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TO MAKE ABORTION RARE.
BUT DOING THIS WILL ACTUALLY.
MAKE IT EASIER SO I'M JUST YOU
KNOW THE AND THAT'S JUST A
STATEMENT OF MINE.
BUT I WANTED TO ASK THE DOCTOR --
THE OP OPPONENTS.
IF I MAY -- SO.
AT AND I'VE YOU KNOW DONE
RESEARCH BECAUSE I HAD A BILL
COUPLE YEARS AGO REGARDING THE
ARE YOU.
FORTY SIX AS WELL -- SO.
AND YOU KNOW YOU WOULD NOW I
MEAN IF SOMEONE TAKES THIS
MEDICATION.
THERE'S GOING TO BE BLEEDING.
THERE'S GOING TO BE PAYING
THERE'S GOING TO BE -- POSSIBLE
ISSUES LIKE YOU SAID THERE'S
SOMETIMES SEVERE CONDITIONS.
BASICALLY THE BABY HAS TO BE
EXPELLED.
AND THAT COULD HAPPEN IN THE
DORM BATHROOM WELL THE GIRL LONG.
AND I'M A MOM AND I YOU KNOW
THEY'RE CONSIDERED ADULTS AT
EIGHTEEN AND YOU KNOW I HAVE A
SON WHO'S EIGHTEEN AND IT'S HARD
TO IMAGINE THAT THEY CAN.
REALLY MAKE ADULT DECISIONS.
BUT MY HEART GOES OUT TO THESE
YOUNG WOMEN WHO WILL BE ALONE IN
THE DORM [inaudible]
EXPONENT CHILD.
IN A AND ONE IS THE DOCTOR I
MEAN WHAT HAPPENS.
WHAT'S THE REALITY OF TAKING
THIS PILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
IT IS TRUE THAT WHEN A WOMAN
TAKES THE PILLS INVOLVED IN THE
MEDICAL ABORTION PROCEDURE.
SHE IS GOING TO EXPERIENCE
PRETTY SEVERE CRAMPING VERY
HEAVY BLEEDING THAT'S SOMETHING
I THINK THAT WE ALL AGREE UPON
THAT PATIENTS ARE INFORMED ABOUT.
SOMETIMES THE BLEEDING IS SO
SEVERE THAT PATIENTS NEED TO GO
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM SOMETIMES
JUST FOR REASSURANCE THAT THERE
THERE THERE'S NOT HEMORRHAGING
TO THE POINT OF NEEDING.
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE BUT SOMETIMES
THEY ARE BLEEDING THAT HEAVILY
THAT THEY DO NEED AN URGENT
PROCEDURE. TO COMPLETE THE
ABORTION TO REMOVE TISSUE FROM
THE WOMB -- AND SOMETIMES EVEN A
BLOOD TRANSFUSION THE FACT IS
THAT IF CURRENTLY WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES ARE IN
LIVING SITUATIONS WHERE
TRANSPORTATION IS DIFFICULT WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT
THEY WOULD BE THE WORST
CANDIDATES. FOR THIS KIND OF
PROCEDURE THEY MAY END UP BY
THEMSELVES BLEEDING HEAVILY IN A
LOT OF PAIN MAYBE NOT ABLE.
TO GET TO A PHONE OR GET TO TO
THE HELP THEY NEED -- THEY WOULD
BE THE THE WORST -- CANDIDATES
FOR THIS KIND OF PROCEDURE AND
AND IT'S GONNA REQUIRE AS I SAID
MORE TIME FOR THEM TO COMPLETE
THE ABORTION PROCEDURE THAN SAY
IF THEY HAD GONE FIRST.
A FIRST TRIMESTER SURGICAL
ABORTION THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION -- JUST AS A FOLLOW UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAY ALSO A MAN
ALSO RESPOND.
WHETHER OR NOT THIS PROCEDURE IS
OFFERED ON CAMPUS WOMEN WILL
STILL AND STUDENTS WILL STILL
HAVE MEANT -- MEDICATED ABORTION
THEY WILL GO OFF CAMPUS TO GET
THE MEDICATION AND THEY WILL
COME BACK AND THEY WILL STILL BE
IN THEIR DORM ROOM SO THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE THAT.
WELL.
IT'S MAKING IT MUCH MORE
AVAILABLE.
ISN'T ISN'T THE POINT I WAS
MAKING THAT IS CORRECT.
WHAT KIND OF SUPERVISION IS
THEIR MEDICALLY ON THE CAMPUS
WHERE AT LEAST?
YOU KNOW THEY GO TO A DOCTOR.
THEY HAVE SOME WAY THEY CAN
CONTACT THE DOCTOR -- FOR THE
NURSE.
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTACT THE HEALTH CENTER AS
WELL.
SO EVEN AFTER HOURS YES SIR IT
WOULD BE SIMILAR TO A FEW IF
THEY OBTAIN THE MEDICATION OFF
CAMPUS AND SOMETHING HAPPENED AT
ONE AM IN THE MORNING.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM WHETHER THEY
OBTAIN THE MEDICATION ON CAMPUS
OR OFF CAMPUS SO THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE.
SO THE I MEAN.
THE IN THE PHYSICIAN WORLD I'M
NOT YOU CAN PRETEND TO BE A
PHYSICIAN.
HOW LATE IN THE PREGNANCY CAN
THEY DO ARE YOU CAN WICKS FOUR
EIGHTY SIX A TEN WEEK TEN WEEKS
SO AT TEN WEEKS?
A PRE BORN CHILD HAS A BEATING
HEART.
ARMS AND LEGS [inaudible]
FEET [inaudible]
HANDS.
I'M JUST YOU KNOW THE MOM IT'S
SYSTEMATIC TO THINK OF A YOUNG
GIRL ALONE.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS SO I MEAN FOR
ME I JUST THINK?
AND I'LL JUST MAKE MY STATEMENT
SB THREE TWENTY DOES NOTHING FOR
PREGNANT STUDENTS WHO WANT TO
KEEP THEIR BABIES IN THE HELP TO
DO SO.
THE ONLY ASSISTANCE THE
UNIVERSITY WILL GIVE THEM HIS.
HAVING ABORTIONS SO WE ALREADY
PROVIDE PREGNANCY COUNSELING
COUNSELING ON ON A CAMPUS THAT
WOULD NOT CHANGE.
AND DID THEY REFER THEM TO
CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS OR THEY
MAY THEY MAY NOT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT EACH CAMPUS TO SPECIFICALLY
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THEY OFFER
PREGNANCY COUNSELING.
SO I I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING A BEFORE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YOUR ATTENTION IN YOUR
DISCUSSION.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
ASKING ANY WOMAN TO HAVE AN
ABORTION THIS BILL IS STILL
MAKING SURE WOMAN HAS HER RIGHT
TO CHOOSE AND WHAT SHE WANTS TO
DO.
IT IS IT IS NO DIFFERENT THAN
TRAVELING OFF CAMPUS DOES IT
MAKE IT MORE ACCESSIBLE
ABSOLUTELY IT DOES THAT IS THE
WHOLE POINT OF THE BILL.
AND SOMETIMES WE JUST HAVE
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENTS IN
LIFE AND THAT'S OKAY -- WELL
OTHER STICKS OR TAKING A GIANT
LEAP BACKWARD TO THE DAYS OF
FORCED PREGNANCY AND MISOGYNY SB
TWENTY FOUR WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD.
BY REAFFIRMING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF COLLEGE
CARE WITHOUT DELAY.
ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
COLLEGE STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FULL RANGE OF
CHOICES OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SO THEY CAN PLANT
THEIR FUTURES AND ACHIEVE THEIR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL GOALS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
LIVE OF THE BILL DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION -- IS THERE
A MOTION.
SECOND.
THE MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A
SECOND BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ ON
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
LAST MINUTE SECTOR TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WHAT I
MAYES MAYES NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA LIMON.
LEVINE AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS [inaudible]
ROBUST HAPPENING.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON NO WATER NO. THREE THE
VOTERS FIVE TO THREE WE STILL
HAVE MEMBERS MISSING I WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SURE
THINK A MEMBER OF THE BILL I DO
AND AND AND AND AND AND AND
THAT'S J. R. YES.
THANK YOU ALL TO THE WITH THE TO
ALWAYS IS A CAME AND I'M WITH
SHOUT OUT TO ALL THE UC OUR
HIGHLANDERS THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] THREE ONE
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR MANY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT.
WELCOME.
A CONCERTED EFFORT TO EXPAND TO
PROTECT QUALITY FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES BUT RECENT CHANGES IN
FEDERAL POLICIES JEOPARDIZE
ACCESS TO THOSE CRITICAL
SERVICES.
PART OF THAT COMMITMENT IS
FAMILY PACKED WHICH IS A
MEDICAID PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
DH CS FAMILY BACK SERVICES
INCLUDE ALL FDA APPROVED
CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTIVES TESTING AND
TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
AND URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS
ALONG WITH SCREENING FOR BREAST
AND CERVICAL CANCER.
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM SERVES
ONE POINT ONE MILLION LOW INCOME
AND UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH TWO TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PROVIDERS CURRENTLY FAMILY PACK
IS FUNDED BY A NINETY TEN
FEDERAL MATCH.
MEANING THAT FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR INVESTED IN FAMILY
PLANNING CARE THE STATE RECEIVES
NINETY CENTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS FEDERAL
PROPOSALS HAVE CALLED FOR
SHIFTING ALL FEDERAL MEDICAID
FUNDING TO STATES TO A BLOCK
GRANT FORM IF SUCH PROPOSALS
WERE TO BE IMPLEMENTED THE
CURRENT MATCH FOR FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
COULD BE THREATENED WITHOUT A
PLAN IN PLACE ACCESS TO FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES FOR LOW INCOME
AN UNINSURED CALIFORNIANS COULD
BE DISRUPTED AND SIGNIFICANTLY
READ AND REDUCED.
SB THRILL ONE PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THAT PLAN.
IN THE EVENT OF REDUCTIONS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING SB THREE OH ONE
WOULD REQUIRE DH CS TO SUBMIT A
PLAN TO THE LEGISLATURE WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF ANY FEDERAL ACTION.
THAT WILL ALTER CURRENT FUNDING
AND ENSURING THE SUSTAINABILITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY PACKED
PROGRAM HERE WITH ME IN SUPPORT
IS SYLVIA SYLVIA CASTILLO FROM
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH.
MOVE THE BILL SECOND
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN A
MEMBERS MY NAME'S LIBYA CAST YOU
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH -- WE
CHAMPION PROMOTE QUALITY SECTION
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED THE FAMILY PACKED
PROGRAM IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AS A MEDICAID WAIVER
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WITH THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING COST EFFECTIVE.
WITH WITH THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF MAKING
FAMILY PLANNING CARE WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE.
AND THE PROGRAM HAS CONTINUOUSLY
PROVEN ITS SUCCESS PROGRAM
EVALUATION BY UC SAN FRANCISCO
SHOW THAT EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON
THE PROGRAM THE PUBLIC SECTOR
SAVES NINE DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FIVE CENTS IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICE EXPENSES.
WITH PAST THREE DECADES FAMILY
PACKED ENTITLED TEN APARTMENT TO
REDUCED UNINTENDED PREGNANCY
RATES IN OUR STATE TO HISTORIC
LOWS.
IN THAT THIRTY YEAR SPAN
CALIFORNIA REDUCE ITS TEEN
PREGNANCY RATE BY 70%.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALREADY ATTACKED REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES CALIFORNIA
MUST TAKE STEPS TO PLAN FOR ALL
SCENARIOS.
INCLUDING A POTENTIAL FUNDING
LOSS FOR THE FAMILY PACK PROGRAM.
TO PROTECT ACCESS TO VITAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY ENACTED
SEVERAL MEASURES MEASURES TO
HOLD THE LINE AND PROTECT ACCESS
IN THE FACE OF HOSTILE ACTIONS
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
SB THRILL ONE WOULD JUST SIMPLY
CALLING DTS TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN SHOULD
FEDERAL FUNDING CHANGES OCCUR
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE.
MUCH OTHER SINCE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN THIS
DISTRICT NINE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
RACHEL TELL ACCESS WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE INSTRUCTOR.
THANK YOU.
KATHY BURKE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW MUCH FOR TO
PROFESSOR MEDICINE IN SUPPORT
WOULD POINT OUT THAT WELL RATES
OF MATERNAL MORTALITY HAVE BEEN
INCREASING AROUND THE COUNTRY
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
WHERE WE'VE SEEN PRETTY TO
MATERNAL DEATH GO DOWN.
THE FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM
DESERVES A LARGE TO CREDIT FOR
ALLOWING WOMEN WITH CHRONIC
MEDICAL CONDITIONS TAXES FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES WHETHER OR NOT
THEY HAVE BEEN CAN TO DO SO
INDEPENDENTLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEE NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN NUMBERS LIKE CLOSE CENTER
LIVE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL DOESN'T DO ENJOY A DO PAT
DOES IT DOESN'T DO IT DOES ENJOY.
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION IT
ISN'T EASY FOR ME TO SAY
APPARENTLY -- WE HAVE POLLUTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ THE LAST MAN
SECRETIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE BONTA [inaudible]
WORK CARILLO. FOR AYE FLORA AYE
LIMóN.
THE MOON I MCCARTY.
AREA RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO WALDRON [inaudible]
WATCH.
YOU HAVE A BOAT SET THOSE THAT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF A FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON AND FINALLY YOU
HAVE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS J. R..
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MEMBERS TITLE
TEN IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM DEDICATED TO FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES.
THESE IMPORTANT SERVICES INCLUDE
CONTRACEPTIVE CARE PREGNANCY
TESTING DIAGNOSING AND TREATING
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
INFERTILITY SERVICE SIZE FUNDING
REGULATIONS FOR TITLE.
TEN THESE REGULATIONSTONIGHT
PATIENTS INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS DISRUPT THE
PROPRIETOR RIP PROVIDER PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP AND TO TURN
CALIFORNIA'S FROM ACCESSING CARE.
BY TYING FEDERAL FUNDING TO
THESE REGULATIONS MANY HEALTH
CARE ORGANIZATIONS AND QUALIFIED
FAMILY PLANNING PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN A CRITICAL FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND ACCEPTING REGULATIONS THAT
WILL REDUCE ACCESS TO QUALITY
TIME SAYS IF CARE FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS ACCORDING TO ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HELP APPROX WE ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIAN.
ARE SERVED BY TITLE TEN PROGRAMS
ACCOUNTING 425% OF TOTAL TEN
PATIENTS NATIONWIDE.
IN WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS SYLVIA
CASTILLO FROM ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH.
HELLO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK --
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH WE
ADMINISTER THE TITLE TEN PROGRAM
HERE IN THE STATE -- OUR NETWORK
IT OF OUR NETWORK OF CLINICS
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE CLINIC PROVIDERS THAT
SERVE A MILLION PATIENTS EACH
YEAR.
SO THE AGENCY THAT RECEIVED THE
SPENDING INCLUDE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS URBAN
INDIAN HEALTH CENTERS UNIVERSITY
AFFILIATES PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES AND OTHER WOMEN'S
HEALTH CENTERS.
SEVERAL CITY AND COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ALSO RECEIVE
TITLE TEN FUNDING INCLUDING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
IN THE COUNTIES OF TULARE
SEVERNA DINO LOS ANGELES SAN
LUIS OBISPO BUTTE NEVADA SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE CITY OF
BERKLEY.
ALL OF THESE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WOULD BE AFFECTED IF
THESE REGULATIONS WOULD TAKE UP
AT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED OR FINAL RULES ARE
HARMFUL IN A LAWFUL AND
REPRESENT SOME OF THE MOST
EXTREME POLICY CHANGES.
PROPOSED TO TITLE TEN SINCE THE
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THE REGULATIONS
WITH TONIGHT PATIENTS QUALITY
CARE THAT THEY RELY ON ON THIS
PROGRAM AND WE CANNOT ALLOW THE
TRUMP PENS ADMINISTRATION. TO
CREATE A TWO TIERED HEALTH
SYSTEM THAT DICK TAKES DIFFERENT
LOWER STANDARDS OF CARE FOR LOW
INCOME AND AN INSURED PATIENTS.
WE THINK CENTER TO LABEL FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
TITLE TEN PROGRAM AND CALLING ON
HHS TO RESCIND THE REGULATIONS.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD BE A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES AND COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING ACCESS TO QUALITY
REPRODUCTIVE AND HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WHETHER OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSEPHINE
FIGARO ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER GOT A LOT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IN A SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
LINDA DINNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
SHANNON HOW THIS NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MOVE THE RESOLUTION.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR WE RESPECTFULLY ASK CAN
I HOPE THANK SENATOR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ THE
MOTION IS THAT THE RESOLUTION BE
A TOP -- AND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHEN I WHEN I NAY
HE'S.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE CARRILLO.
FLORA.
FLOOR NO LIMóN.
Là MON I MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS HI RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO WALDRON
[inaudible] SIX WE HAVE A FOR A
CHANGE OF VOTE MY MISTER BIGELOW
FROM HEIGHTS AND NO.
THANKS TO KNOW.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
HERE -- FIVE FIVE TO TO THE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SENATOR BRADFORD.
YES.
I WOULD WITH A MOTION TO MOVE
THE CONSENT AGENDA.
AND THE SECOND A MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
BIGELOW MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
WHICH INCLUDES ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB ONE FIFTY FOUR PAN RIGHT
NUMBER SIX SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
A HEALTH COMMITTEE WILL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES I
AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER CURRY I
BIGELOW?
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BURKE CARRILLO
FLORA FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
SO WE CAN SET THE AGENDA IS
PASSED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SENATOR BRADFORD PLEASE
CALL.
THE BILL YEAH SEE YOU IS THAT
WASN'T WORTH IT WASN'T WORTH IT.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS AND
CHEER ALL THIS IS STRAIGHT FOR
MEASURE SB THREE TWO TWO TO
SUPPORTS NURSES NURSES AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK PART PRIVATELY WITH.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WHEN THEY'RE CONDUCTING
AN INSPECTION CURRENTLY -- THEY
CAN DO IT WILL ONLY WOULD KILL
OFF CAL LEAVE THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE NEW WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS HEALTHCARE WORKERS
ARE ALREADY PROTECTED UNDER THE
LAW FIRM RETALIATION FOR
REPORTING PATIENT SAFETY OR
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES.
SB THREE TWENTY TWOS LANGUAGE
UNDER THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
WAS DRAFTED BASED ON THE
EXISTING LAW UNDER THE LABOR
CODE FOR CALLOSUM.
LET'S LET NURSES DO WHAT THEY DO
BEST AND BE PATIENT ADVOCATES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SCENERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY.
MR MAYS AND A SECOND BY MISS.
THEIR BIGELOW -- MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
LIKE THE CLOSENESS RADFORD.
TAKE ABOUT FIVE MINUTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU HAVE A OKAY
YOU'RE THE CLOCKS AGAIN THOUGH
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHEN I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW BIG.
BIGELOW I BONTA BURKE.
CARRILLO.
FLORA FLOOR AYE LIMóN.
LIMON I MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I RAMOS RAMOS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON. NINE THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR.
NOW WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL WAIT
WE HAVE -- SENATOR.
WE CAN GO TO THE OTHER BILLS AND
TAKE -- YOU CAN ADD ON WE'LL DO
THAT SIR OKAY.
SO SIR WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA --
ITEM NUMBER TWO AND SIX WERE
DISCOUNT -- GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLE IN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
BONTA BURKE CARRILLO.
MCCARTY IN THIS AREA CARILLO
CARILLO ON THE ON HI.
NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO WALDRON. TEN
SO THAT'S TEN WE'LL GO BACK TO
SB TWENTY FOUR AND WILL OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA BURKE.
FLORA
NO FLOOR NOW [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO. SIXTY FOUR
SO THAT'S IT'S AT SIXTY FOUR OF
THEM NUMBER THREE SB THREE OH
ONE PLEASE OPEN.
LIFT THE CALL NO OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SORRY.
BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO.
SB THREE OH ONE ITEM.
THREE CARILLO I MCCARTY
NECESSARY IN.
THIS AREA I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
TENSOR THAT'S TEN ZERO WE ALL
JUST VOTED ON S. B. -- THREE
TWENTY TWO S. B. S. J. R. FOR
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SEVEN PLEASE -- LIFT THE CALL
THE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO [inaudible]
I MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
THIS IS AT SEVEN TWO SO.
WE'RE ALL CAUGHT UP [inaudible]
AND OKAY THANK YOU.
AND ACTUALLY SERVICE SERVICE WE
HAVE THE OTHER MEMBERS COLOR OF
THE MEMBERS.
BE REALLY HELPFUL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IF
SENATOR.
IT DOESN'T GET MUCH BETTER THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR READY FOR ME
PLEASE.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF SB EIGHT SEVEN
FOUR SIX REQUIRES HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE PROVIDERS.
THAT ALREADY COVER CHEMOTHERAPY
OR RADIATION THERAPY TO COVER
ANTI CANCER MEDICAL DEVICES AS
OF JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TUMOR TREATING
FIELDS TTF THERAPY IS A
BREAKTHROUGH TREATMENT OF SOLID
TUMOR CANCERS.
IT HAS BEEN APPROVED FOR THE
TREATMENT OF GEO BLAST DONNA
BRAIN CANCER AND THE RIGOROUS
FEDERAL.
FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION PRE
MARKET APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
CLASS THREE MEDICAL DEVICES.
GBM IS MOST COMMON AN AGGRESSIVE
PRIMARY BRAIN CANCER IN
PROGRESSIVE RAPIDLY.
TTF THERAPY HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
SIGNIFICANTLY EXTEND THE LIVES
AND FUNCTIONALITY OF GBM
PATIENTS GETTING CARE EARLY.
AND IMMEDIATELY IS CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE DEVICE IN
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
NOW THAT ANTI CANCER MEDICAL
DEVICES ARE A BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICE AND THE TREATMENT OF
CANCER IN SHOULD BE COVERED.
SB SEVEN FORTY SIX WILL MAKE IT
CLEAR AND COLD THAT HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED
TO COVER ANTI CANCER MEDICAL
DEVICES IF THE ALREADY COVER
CHEMOTHERAPY OR RADIATION
THERAPY.
THE SB SEVEN FORTY SIX ALSO
DEFINES AN ANTI CANCER MEDICAL
DEVICE AS A DEVICE THAT IS
APPROVED.
BY THE FEDERAL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION USE PRIMARILY
OUTSIDE OF A MEDICAL TREATMENT
FACILITY.
INDETERMINATE SHOULD BE
NECESSARY IN THE TREATMENT OF
CANCER.
THESE DEVICES HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN REPEATED
STUDIES AND TO APPROVED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THEIR USE
NATIONWIDE SO IT IS CRITICAL FOR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. TO COVER
THESE DEVICES QUICKLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM GBM
OR OTHER TYPES OF CANCER WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JUSTIN
KELLY WITH NO WILL CURE.
WHO CAN ANSWER ANY THE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DEVICE AND
HOW IT OPERATES?
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
SORRY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JUSTIN CALLIE AND THE
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I'M HERE -- TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND PASSING THIS BILL --
CLEAR BLAST ALMOST MULTI FORM IS
THE DISEASE THAT KILLED SENATORS
TED KENNEDY AND JOHN MCCAIN.
AND VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S SON
BEAU.
OPPORTUNE AS AN ANTI CANCER
DEVICE FDA APPROVED FOR THE
TREATMENT BOTH WERE CURRENT AS
WELL AS NEWLY DIAGNOSED CLEO
BLAST FROM A BRAIN TUMORS IT'S
INCLUDED IN THE NATIONAL
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER NETWORK --
GUIDELINES FOR BOTH NEWLY
DIAGNOSED WERE CURRENTLY --
BLAST OMA IN HIS PART OF THE GPL
MARKLEY LESS FROM A STANDARD OF
CARE.
VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR INSURANCE
CARRIER IN THE UNITED STATES AND
MANY MEDICAID PROGRAMS INCLUDING
MEDICAL HAVE PUBLISHED COVERAGE
POLICIES.
OF FOR THIS THERAPY AT THIS
POINT IN TIME MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION AMERICANS
ARE COVERED FOR TO RETREATING
FIELDS IN THE EVENT OF A PLEA --
BLAST FROM A DIAGNOSIS.
BOB TUNE IS OFTEN COVERED SOME
PLANTS COVER INCONSISTENTLY --
OFTEN TO THE GREAT DETRIMENT OF
PATIENT TO PURCHASE THEIR PLANS
ON THE INDIVIDUAL OR SMALL GROUP
MARKET.
ALL PATIENTS WERE COVERED
THROUGH LARGE GROUP OR EMPLOYER
PLANS ARE TYPICALLY COVERED THIS
IS RESULTED IN PATIENTS WHO ARE
NOT INSURED THROUGH -- THROUGH
LARGE EMPLOYERS HAVING TO FOREGO
TREATMENT HAD A POCKET OR SEEK
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCES FOR
STANDARD OF CARE TREATMENT.
THAT FOR MANY PATIENTS IS ARE
ONLY AVAILABLE OPTION -- I'D
LIKE TO SHARE A LETTER FROM --
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY FROM
WATSONVILLE RESIDENT.
LIVING WITH WILL LAST A MONTH HE
PURCHASES HEALTH PLAN TO COVER
CALIFORNIA AND RAN INTO THE
ISSUE THIS BILL INTENSE DEFECTS.
I BELIEVE HIS LETTER UNDERSCORES
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION
AND THE REAL HUMAN IMPACT THIS
ISSUE HAS ON SOME CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IMPACTED BY THIS BILL.
IT TOOK THIRTEEN MONTHS -- TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE FOR HIM
THROUGH THE APPEAL PROCESS AND
THESE ARE PATIENTS WERE BATTLING
A DEADLY DISEASE AND FRANKLY
DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO NAVIGATE.
A LENGTHY APPEALS PROCESS IN
THESE INSTANCES.
THE TESTIMONY BEFORE THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WHEN THEY
CONSIDER THIS BILL WE HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM INSURANCE
COMPANIES INDICATING THAT ALL
PLANTS COVER THE TREATMENT.
I KNOW IF THIRTY INSTANCES OF
THE LAST THREE YEARS WERE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WERE DENIED
CARE.
DUE TO THE AMBIGUITY THIS BILL
INTENDS TO CLARIFY.
INCLUDING THREE RESIDENTS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY NAVIGATING THE
APPEALS PROCESS TODAY.
IN CLOSING THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE WE
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE IMPACTS
VERY FEW CALIFORNIANS.
BUT FOR THOSE THAT IT DOES
IMPACT.
THE MAGNITUDE CAN BE
CATASTROPHIC BOTH MEN --
MEDICALLY AS WELL AS FINANCIALLY.
IT'S DIAGNOSED WITH GLIOBLASTOMA
HAVE VERY FEW OPTIONS AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
AND WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION TO
ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
COMPARABLE ACCESS INTO CANCER
MEDICAL DEVICES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DENNIS CARDOZA
REPRESENTING FOLEY AND LARDNER
AND KNOW WE CARE IT'S THE FIRST
TIME I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE I WAS
A MEMBER OF THIS A GLASS BODY
TESTIFYING AND THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER TESTIMONY I JUST
WANNA -- SAY THAT WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NO ONE ANSWERED OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
STEPHANIE WHY CAN SOMEBODY HAVE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES REGRETTABLY WE ARE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION. TO
UNDERSCORE WHAT WAS TESTIFIED TO
EARLIER WE ARE UNABLE TO
IDENTIFY ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
CURRENTLY THAT ARE NOT COVERING
THIS AND TREATMENT I THINK THERE
WERE SOME ISSUES AND
CLARIFICATIONS THAT HAPPENED
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
I KNOW THE INDIVIDUALLY PLANS
HAVE GONE INTO THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TO TRY AND SHARE THAT.
IT IS NOW COVERED -- MOST
RECENTLY KAISER HAS ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT IT IS COVERED THEREFORE IT
IS A PART OF THE BENCHMARK PLAN.
WITH THAT WE BELIEVE THAT BOTH --
WITHIN THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL
ROUP MARKET THAT WOULD BE --
REQUIRED COVERAGE FOR ALL OTHER
PLANS SO WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSORS THAT THERE'S
INDIVIDUAL INSTANCES FOR WHICH
WE CAN LEND SOME SUPPORT THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT IT IS A
REQUIRED COVERAGE UNDER THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
BENCHMARK PLANT.
SO WITH THAT UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION WE THINK IT'S
UNNECESSARY IN THE CONTEXT THAT
IF WE START -- TO CODIFY ALL
INDIVIDUAL TREATMENT MODALITIES
CERTAINLY THAT WILL OPEN THIS UP
TO A MUCH BROADER CONVERSATION
IN THE CONCERNED SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER ONLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS I'D LIKE TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
I MISSED WHAT CANS BUT REALLY I
MEAN THIS IS A CASE WHERE IT IS
AN EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT THE
BENCHMARK PLAN.
IS A KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY'RE
COVERING IT ALL OTHER PLANTS IN
THE SMALL MARCH ERIC THIS SMALL
AN INDIVIDUAL MARKET.
SHOULD BE COVERING THE SERVICE
AND SO WE DO HAVE A REAL CONCERN
JUST ABOUT TO KEY TAG EVEN OUR
KNOCKS KEEN ACT WITH WITH
SERVICES AND DEVICES THAT ARE
COVERED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE ARE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WHICH IS
A LINER COMMENTS WITH BACK
LOOKING CAP.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- WE DO HAVE -- I'M
I'M CURIOUS I I DO HAVE A
QUESTION SO [inaudible]
SO.
THE HEALTH PLANS YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THIS IS COVERED AND SO THIS
BILL IS UNNECESSARY SO.
IS THAT WHY IS THERE A PROBLEM
WITH.
WE HAVE I HAVE TALKED TO THE THE
PROPONENTS AND THERE THERE DO
APPEAR TO BE STILL PEOPLE WHO
DON'T.
PLANS IT DON'T GET IT FOR
WHATEVER REASON WE'RE NOT
COVERING FOR WHATEVER REASON SO
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S COVERED AND
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE DOING IT.
WHY SHOULD WHY OTHER PLANTS THAT
ARE NOT CURRENTLY DOING THAT AND
SO WHY SHOULD WE NOT STATE THIS
INTO INTO LAW TO TO ENSURE THAT
ITS IT THAT IT IS BEING FOLLOWED?
I THINK A RESPONSE WOULD BE I
MEAN THERE'S THERE'S PLENTY OF
INSTANCES FROM WHICHSOMETHING
IS CLEARLY COVERED AND THERE IS
AN ISSUE AND THERE'S A
REGULATORY PROCESS BOTH THEIR
CDI AND TEAMMATES SEE. TO GO
THROUGH THAT IF IF WE WERE TO
CODIFY EVERY INSTANCE FOR WHICH
THERE WAS A ONE OFF WHERE THERE
WAS A MISTAKE IN COVERAGE OR AN
ISSUE.
I MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NOT
SKINNER AND INSURANCE COULD
WOULD LOOK LIKE I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S WHAT OUR CONCERN IS THAT
THERE'S A WHOLE REGULATORY.
PROCESS IN ORDER TO SET FOR THE
BENCHMARK PLAN TO ITEMIZE WHAT
COVERAGE LOOKS LIKE AND THAT'S
BETTER PLACED IN THAT REGULATORY
PROCESS AND ALSO HAVING THE I AM
OUR PROCESS FOR SECONDARY LOOK
AT THAT GIVES.
INDIVIDUALS AN OPPORTUNITY WHEN
THERE ARE CONCERNS OR PROBLEMS
LEGISLATING EVERY TIME THAT
THERE'S A ONE OFF MEANS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE QUITE OFTEN
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
SOMETHING IS NECESSARY OR NOT
AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
KIND OF WINNERS AND LOSERS
PEOPLE WHO GET THERE DEVICE OR
THE MODALITY CODIFIED VERSUS
THOSE THAT DON'T I THINK THAT'S
OUR GENERAL CONCERN.
WELL IT'S A I SHARE SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL -- I
DON'T WANT TO BE HERE EVERY YEAR.
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT INDIVIDUAL
DEVICES BUT I I THINK WHAT I
JUST HEARD YOU SAY IS THAT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S COVERED.
OR MAYBE PEOPLE DON'T GET THE
COVERAGE AND THAT'S I THINK THAT
IS TO THE POINT OF WHAT THE
PROPONENTS HER ASKING MISTER
DISCOVERY OF ETIQUETTE.
IF IT'S A COVERED BENEFIT -- I'M
SO I'M JUST.
FIVE NINE AND I THINK THAT THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF REASONS THAT
COULD OCCUR.
FOR A PLAN TO A WHEN REVIEWING
THE REQUEST FOR ANY YOU KNOW A
DEVICE OR INCLUDING THIS DEVICE.
OR MAYBE THERE WASN'T --
INITIALLY THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
INFORMATION SUBMITTED BY THE%
PROVIDER TO DOCUMENT MEDICAL
NECESSITY I MEAN THERE'S JUST
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY THAT WOULD
BE.
THAT IT WOULD BE EXAMINED BY THE
PLAN BUT AGAIN THAT'S WHY THERE
IS THE INTERNAL APPEALS PROCESS.
AND OF THE I AM OUR PROCESS AT
THE DEPARTMENT TO KIND TO
RESOLVE THOSE WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
WILL JUDGING BY THE THE
AGGRESSIVE NATURE OF A DISEASE
LIKE THIS AND THE LENGTH OF
APPEALS -- THAT MIGHT TAKE I
THINK WE HEARD FROM THE
PROPONENTS THAT WE WANT ONE
APPEAL TOOK THIRTEEN MONTHS --
AND CONSIDERING THE THE
EXTREMELY AGGRESSIVE NATURE OF
AN ADDITION LIKE THIS -- I'D.
I FEEL SO.
FEELS PRETTY PRETTY ROUGH ON THE
PATIENT QUITE FRANKLY SO -- I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO SPEAK PART OF
THAT -- BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU'VE HIT.
PRECISELY THE PROBLEM THE WERE
AFTER -- OFTENTIMES OF THESE
PATIENTS ARE GETTING THE
TREATMENT IMMEDIATELY -- THEY
MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
TREATMENT THREE FOUR FIVE MONTHS
DOWN THE ROAD.
THIS TAKES ALL -- EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS WE HEARD THIS SAME
TESTIMONY IN THE SENATE.
AND THEY SAID THERE WAS NO ONE
NOT COVERING IT BUT AS WE
TESTIFIED EARLIER MISTER MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER KELLY TESTIFIED.
THERE ARE THREE PEOPLE CURRENTLY
THAT WE ARE AWARE OF THAT --
HAVE BEEN ADDED I COVERAGE ARE
GOING THROUGH APPEAL PROCESS
THIS IS NOT A SITUATION OF THOSE
PATIENTS HAVE THE TIME. TO BE
DILLY DALLYING AROUND WITH THE
APPROVAL PROCESS WE NEED TO
TREATMENT AS SOON AS ARE
DIAGNOSED SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE
THE BEST CHANCE FOR SURVIVAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
TINA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR.
I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I YES I I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIEND I
BELIEVE AND I THINK -- I WAS
DRIVEN TO TAKE THIS -- HAVING
EXPERIENCE WITH A CLOSE FRIEND
WHO DID PASS AWAY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR DISEASE AND THE
SIGNIFICANCE IS THERE OF THE
REPEATED TEA AT WHICH THIS
DEVICE NEEDS TO BE APPLIED.
SOMEONE DIAGNOSED WITH OUT AND
THE APPEAL PROCESS DOES NOT
SERVE THEM WELL SO IT'S MY HOPE
THAT WE'LL GET AN AYE VOTE IN
AND MOVE THE BILL ALONG THANK
YOU.
Q. -- WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS A MOTION
BY IT WAS BY MR FLOOR THE SECOND
BY WAS BY MISTER MASON MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WHAT I MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA.
I BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. THREE A
I FLORA FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
JERRY AND I RAMOS ROSS I
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
SO YOUR BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
IT'S OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE
THE LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE ARE JUST AS A WARNING TO
OTHER MEMBERS IT HAVING VOTED --
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FIVE MINUTES--
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON MISTER
BONTA IF YOU'D LIKE.
TO I THINK YOU.
AND MISS BURKE WILL GO THROUGH
WILL GO THROUGH THE VOTES HERE.
SO WE'LL GO THROUGH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AND SIX A SET SB ONE FIFTY
FOUR PAN AS SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOR
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE -- THEN YOU
ARE.
SECRETARY PLEASE -- OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
AYE [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
THIRTEEN THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER WILL GO BACK IN AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM NUMBER -- ONE
WE WILL -- LIFT THE CALL AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND SECRETARY.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE. TEN TEN
FOR THAT BILL HAS TEN VOTES IT'S
OUT OF COMMITTEE -- TEND TO FOUR
IS THE VOTE ON THAT ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB THREE OH ONE SLAVE UP
PLEASE -- LIFT THE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SKIS ME
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE HI.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HI SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
FOURTEENTH.
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB THREE TWENTY TWO WILL
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. FOURTEEN
ZERO AND THEN -- WE JUST DID --
WELL ACTUALLY THIS WILL OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
ITEM FIVE SB SEVEN FORTY SIX
MAIN.
CENTER AYE WALDRON.
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO AND THEN
FINALLY -- WILL LIFT THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN S. J. R. FOR BY
CENTER LEYVA.
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE AND WALDRON.
THAT IS.
ELEVEN TO TWO RIGHT ON THAT WE
HAVE A CONSECUTIVAS TO CARTY
MCCARTY WHICH TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR VIEW WHAT WE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL.
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MCCARTY
MCCARTY I THAT IS.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN OKAY --
OKAY.
I THINK WITH THAT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE THIS.
OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH